hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Resident Evil 7 now
there's been brand spankin new DLC added
to the game first starting off with not
a hero which is a DLC that was planned
for I believe this spring but it was way
too late and then end of Zowie which is
a story of Joe Baker Jack's unheard of
brother so we're gonna start with not a
hero because it says weeks after not a
hero so I'm assuming then not a hero
needs to be played first but I am gonna
play a ball to show don't you worry
about that
let's see what's awaiting it's been oh
hey okay alright then
normal I'm real good at this game oh
it's this guy Chris Redfield is a high
profile BSA a member who has resolved
many bioterrorism crisis over his lingo
alright then hmm okay
I can't help man we've got work to do
that's a close-up of a news
oh wait am I gonna be playing as you
never mind that I don't even remember
your name it's been so long
well hi bye okay see you hmm no no
winners has been secured he's alive and
well considering he's next on my list ah
oh this is immediately after the main
game just ended after you fight uh the
little grandma lady girl thing whatever
you would call it oh no I'm gonna kick
some ass aw it's been so long since I've
been in this game oh I love it I love
this game to death I played it a lot in
my spare time to like the unlimited
modes that they had were really fun Oh
get an armor system oh brother
I bet this isn't gonna infect me yeah
yeah by myself if three people died then
I'm sure to do fine on my own was gonna
be good oh god it's been so long you
have like a ha ha ha yeah comment knife
okay so I got that I got this you're
gonna grenade three of those okay all
right let's do this
let's do this it's been a while since I
played a block okay blocks still the
same oh boo dopey come on Oh
want some you want some
that yeah you want some more lap hopped
like a red balloon you can punch enemies
when they stagger how do I punch a
button for punching well that's a reload
whoa hey
well ball punch with wow I punched the
[ __ ] out of you hey expect my punch to
be that potent right hey I'm sorry about
that excuse you I was interrupted I'll
punch him later there's a problem with
the punching trainer whoa Oh a punch
without Oh Oh
so I don't even need a switch in my
melee oh yeah damn it god damn it
just wasted some bullets on you [ __ ]
that's fine I think I know what I'm
doing yah oh yeah seems like he might be
I never become a part of those
experiments oh now that you said that
I'm pretty sure that's exactly what
happened those men oh yeah okay well
alright let's see what you got Chris
Redfield on the job anybody want to
shoot E who's moaning in the distance
and why isn't that moan not covered in
bullets hello Lucas hello do I remember
how to open it I do
oh hi hello are you dead or dying get
you believe me it's too late why is it
too late it's walking out of here
now you can try and take that off all
you want but I'd advise against a lot of
sink there but ok ok well I think you
already did it to the soldier friend
there you [ __ ] oh wow that's not good
my hand ok do I get out of here oh I
should I'll catch you probably skedaddle
huh
probably move I don't have time to look
at things work benches in the such like
as oh hello was that oh thank you for
watching on me I'll need you to help me
out I know how that sucks I want to give
that [ __ ] a head start
yeah ok don't you know I got goop juice
to get that back on me yeah you think
I'm worried about that Chris Redfield
not worried about no I misread feel
worried about you I'm a part that is
such a pouch
alright plomp now I gotta wait for this
bad boy oh no I don't nevermind
hoods instant Danny is here a dachshund
kind of a problem right man why is he
able to do that stuff I thought all this
stuff died when you know lady girl
find him and bring him in we can't let
this happen what's the connection you
still want to recruit him maybe the BSAA
is convinced if they weren't I wouldn't
be here working with umbrellas gonna
take some getting used to a conversation
when you get back I still don't know why
Chris is working with umbrella like I
don't know the timeline yet I'm not a
hundred percent sure where everything
stands but I guess we're probably gonna
find out in this one if we're gonna play
as Chris ooh ha ha ho dere I like the
big red clown that's all I really like
well who is av okay someone do that
first obviously save yes please thank
you okay
Hanigan here Oh a new car thank you I
don't know what I'm gonna do with that
also what did wait what is this stuff a
letter explaining umbrellas new goals
excuse me I don't want you here we go
let's go to this one uh-huh uh-huh
for many of you this is your first
mission with us so we wanted to make it
clear what umbrella is all about though
many of our staff hail from the infamous
pharmaceutical giant umbrella our
purpose is to make amends for the
atrocities perpetuated under the
umbrella name that is why we
reincorporated as a private military
company in 2007 we will put a stop to
not only anyone who is engineering or
selling bio weapons but those who
support those efforts as well we made a
mess and now we have to clean it up by
keeping the umbrella name we show that
we take responsibility for that mess and
we want you to remember that you carry
this responsibility with you in every
mission that doesn't seem right I don't
I don't think that's entirely true I
don't I don't believe you at all in fact
okay lurking fear okay
operation lurking fear primary mission
extract Lukas Baker
location del V Louisiana Baker State
Threat front profile molded alpha
variant others anti-personnel traps
lethal and non
due to the lack of intelligence and the
number of unknown factors involved Chris
Redfield of the BSAA will act as a bio
weapons specialist on mention recent
Intel's confirmed that Lucas paper is
holed up in the mines near the Baker
estate lucas paper whoa there was
another page there wait yeah profiles
suspected associate of criminal
organization the connections roll done
confirmed holds vital Intel regarding
said organization criminal organization
producing bio weapons for sale of
international black more on the limine
series model Evelyn Evelyn Mao's it is
present and active at the Baker estate
Lukas Baker seems to be monitoring
activities reporting under activities
okey-dokey then
alright why let me push this button corn
oh I need a key okay I see all right
well time to hit the old dusty trail
oh sweet how does that mean I should use
this thing now that's just health I
guess you were permanent stat boosts oh
hello ah frag Grenada a good good for me
a huh yeah okay alright I guess I gotta
try to open these things ya know what I
gotta do welcome me my vision device
required whoop I'm scared I don't have
an eye vision device I didn't know if it
was required or not kind of want to go
in there without one but save it for
later
now it's working from okay let's try
this one it's green means good means
beginner baby level I think hello any
but I want to blow up the explosive on
my arm so I can reattach it with goop
juice anybody got any goop juice please
tell me I have goop juice I don't want
to be using these injectors all day oh
that's stupid
terrible oh hello
anybody a welcome me okay alright little
weird ah the clown I remember the clown
and it's horrible machinations okay
alright I don't have a key for you
like stupid mmm hello ah
bio-weapon oh good body also bio-weapon
oh it's bad what do I do about this
high-grade filter required
oh hi brain Oh screw you with your
high-grade filter bowl shootie no no no
don't kill me okay well what are we
gonna do analysis air clear oh thank you
for that man this is a fancy weapon
system I got here so what am I gotta go
through sorry that scared me
it scared me I thought it was an enemy
but it turns out he was not so you got
to be somebody over here maybe this one
up those stairs maybe not sure is any of
these that I can go in tell me your
secrets tell me oh I don't like you sack
tell me all your secrets what am I going
the bug area is that the secret oh hey
buddy you okay in there
okay I guess you don't believe me but
whatever it's gonna happen baby you're
gonna get out of here alive I know that
Lucas guy he don't like his games you're
gonna be fine okay I'll go down here I
have no basis for knowing that the keys
down will up up
we're going up all right up up is a
thing okay we're going up now all right
I'd have no idea that the behind okay
all right I'm wrong in all fronts I have
no knowledge in this place I am just a
visitor and an incredibly stupid one so
who is here to try to take my life away
from me key whoa nope don't like that
alright well going down this uh music
how about what song
and then you're not stunned
you want one miss okay all right well is
it more okay well I got more punches for
dick this is how this is our Chris
Redfield got so jacked in Resident Evil
5 just like unbelievable amounts of
woohoo I'm gonna try to a [ __ ] I can't I
stopped on you I'm trying to stop I ran
out of bullets I was dumb of me okay
alright well boom no oh god that didn't
work who'da thunk I'm gonna throw a
grenade at you hook take some of that
that'll learn you oh it didn't learn him
well they've learned him that time
alright you done are you done are you
done have you learned
oh you haven't learned at all alright
well oh come on man no you're not dead
ain't ya I got you that time he vanished
why did he vanish I like this gun it's a
real real potent ooh is it ticking
wait no just not what I want
I forgot that control is the music tick
tock
okay all right I trust you but barely
but not a lot after my experiences with
that wool way no come on now
aha your heads gone anymore oh no no no
it ain't gonna happen
all right so I took care of those guys
there's a clown door right there oh
that's terrible
okay well don't like that Lucas you goof
man don't goof me like that
ah you goofed me so thusly
oh you're goofy okay I see a gear is
this what I need what about a crank
anybody got a cranky Yankee everybody's
seen one I'm gonna put this on this but
all right gear glam well don't know
handle though well I got shotgun I am I
wanted I do that need some mouse
mysteriously I can't imagine what that
might be
couldn't be oh it couldn't be that thing
up there could it bullets thank you
anybody else anybody else what's this
antique coin yes please okay whoa was
that actually something or is that a
whole lot nothing neuro stun grenade I
don't need those I just need olfaction
bullets that's all I've ever needed
anyway I saw to do it this oughta do it
whoa oh you know imma stop this wait no
oh oh hey I want to stop this boy oh
he's real smoky boy oh god why is he so
good hey he's gonna charge apparently
aah Oh like that you're gross
oh you're steamy boy
yeah hi regeneration target unaffected
oh okay ah he's are coming he's coming
around the map here he comes oh okay I'm
gonna grab the key and I'm not giddy out
of here I guess selkie I guess that's
all I need right I don't really need
anything else remember just need a run
right over there like an idiot I mean
while I'm over here like a smart monk
I'm sure this is gonna work oh wow I
guess I'm this is the elevator of me
being wrong that's all this elevator is
I don't know what the heck I'm doing in
this elbow I got turned this way I'm
alright hello anybody in here anybody
want to jump out of me
here we go who's he gonna work perfectly
hello
oh this is a trap oh it's some kind of
trap oh no everything's all right now
that's just what he wants you to think
I'm just the bait and you fell for it
well you could have told me man oh boy
oh you kind of told me about it take the
filter I'm a mask hurry but you'll die
oh well that's no good geez geez oh geez
oh it's horrible well put it on what
don't be sorry Jesus
Lucas is an [ __ ] and I futile II got
a high grade filter yeah that one guy
had the high grade filter yeah
what contamination filter has been
upgraded alright whatever god dammit god
dammit that's son of a [ __ ] I fine then
I guess I'll go how much contamination
stuff does this guy have why didn't he
use it on Ethan huh damn
alright whatever I'm out of bullets for
that but I got bullets for this I guess
let me tell you all the things I'm gonna
do with my hands to that [ __ ]
yeah that's disappointing
I don't need those do I really need him
alive though do we really I mean we
could afford just a little bit of
maiming I mean you'll regenerate right
Oh mate no isn't the curse like lifted
or something maybe he doesn't have
special powers now
I'm not arms and sure about that but I'm
just gonna go on a wild guess all right
who's down here I hear something
crawling that's better still be up it
all right good
better still be of it good okay good
good good
all right those look like mines
I probably shouldn't touch those Oh
who's who goes there
oh you look a little different
do you look a little different like
crazy are you crazy
you look a little different I don't like
it oh it's a shotgun suggestions ramrods
what ramrod ramrod oh come on why you
gotta be super advanced now
ah man Ethan got it easy Ethan got it
real easy
i-it's stupid is John someone gonna come
hand-deliver it to me or do I have to go
back up and get it myself is that was
you have like a chute a pulley system
that you can deliver it to me so I don't
have it I've made legs are sore from all
my running shame where do I get it all
voice in the sky where do I get this
magical new equipment yeah
where's my ordnance [ __ ] all right
fine I'll go back I'll retreat for now
it's gotta be like an elevator or
something who will be funky funky out
there don't think that you can be funky
thunk when I'm in here all right well
I'm falling back well that didn't work
all right well okay that did a whole lot
of dick diddly what am I supposed to do
about that we're a mess both go hmm I
can't see any place to go so there's
gotta be ramrods down here somewhere I
mean the only way to go is forward so it
might be a way that I can get around
that guy I don't know maybe like some
space that I can make to surround him
cuz if I can do that I can get a little
bit of wide berth
BER th not berth
hello are you still down here you still
down here they're not be
and you better not be oh no he's not
down here Oh mysteriously how strange
peculiar okay all right well where are
you said no he's gonna pop out at the
the least expected moment hey when I
don't want him to okay whatever you say
buddy he's got a lot of neuro stem Oh
neuro stun grenades would work on him
wouldn't they oh if I can't shoot him
then at least I can stun him right I
don't really need the the that right now
yeah that looks good okay I got it
whoa get neuro stunned baby ooh neuro
stun a punch regenerate that [ __ ] oh it
looks like he's regenerating that oh
these neuro stuns work a lot faster than
I expected them to so did quite
anticipate the sudden suddenness of it
oh hey hey whoa whoa that's horrible
glass neuro stun get punched oh [ __ ] I
just neuro stunned myself oh this is
dark well oh oh okay
wasted in neuro sling grenade and
incendiary what and incendiary who's he
what's it where was all this good [ __ ]
wouldn't when Ethan was walking around
why are the ramrod bullets down here why
are they down here all right cool ramrod
bullets down here it makes sense it
makes sense it makes sense everybody it
makes sense
night-vision device SADS night-vision
functionality to a none Briella
night-vision device so I'm out down here
Oh
I got night vision now that's that's
awfully nice oh wait how many ramrod
bullets do I got here we go let me get
my ramrod in here all right it's time to
ram your rod little ram right here to
show you a good time okay is there like
a way to turn on night vision or is that
just gonna activate automagically I'm
gonna guess it's go
is that good or bad I'm gonna guess good
cuz I like to look on the bright side of
life
hello oh not good not good
the answer is not good okay I whoa Wow
all righty then
whoo why does that look like it was
equipped with a BAM
tick-tock wait this isn't my knife I
would've thrown a neuro bomb at that
also this is very convenient incendiary
grenades in grenade form here though I
woulda liked okay I don't hear no
tick-tock haha okay all right anything
else in there nothing
all right down the hole I'm Santa Claus
I went down a chimney all right come a
knife real sneaky-like lovely goop over
there okay what is all this then cause
I'm so weak from punching all these
zombies all right what about this I'm
not sure if this is good or bad what I
just did it's that good or bad
I can't tell all right whatever I'm
gonna hope for the best because I love
Carla bright hello
up down up oh okay thanks for the thanks
for the head I get it I get it I get it
I get it I get it okay oh this is some
outlet it looked like I pushed that up
even though I had to pull it somehow
Chris Redfield just muscles it by
pushing everything Chris Redfield whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey
Oh face humper hey hey hey it's a
freaking head pumper
oh no not my aunt owner oh grenade aah
Frick he used my good ammo damn it
that's what I get all right you know
what I'm a knife up you and you I got
even gonna waste bullets on you yeah
give me out of there
hey no you want some no smash blam god
oh god they're so so fast no no no no no
hey no no no no no walk into my brood of
death no no my blade of death is what
you walk into that now oh crap
well that's not good wait oh god I
killed like your whole family and it's
too there like Goku ah I want to shoot
up hey I get drugs oh there we go
whoa whoa Jesus
sorry for the the nauseating movement
here no oh jeez can I go now can I go
now oh thank you Jesus
ah no oh you wanted to go toe-to-toe
with me huh not today not today okay
all right what else do we have here
lovely more okay all right you know what
into my blade girls nope got him maybe I
should just run for it
oh this is where the tour was ooh that
doesn't sound good
oh hey wait I got super bullet for you
one of them
one bullet yeah nailed it all right well
that did the job one bullet amazing wish
I had more of those whoa oh god I did it
again oh why is control Hill why I've
just used all of my health like a idiot
okay
all right how do I get past you huh I
get past you
Oh like that all right well okay okay
all right then well it's as easy as that
oh hey miss me oh yeah get go get rekt
get rekt all right I only got one bullet
of this but I got shout gun that's
awfully handy in a pinch all right ooh
do I hear another up there
oh I hear something there's something
breathing hello okay weird whoa hey whoa
hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa whoa well
come here shock him punch up or miss
that's also an option boink
potato potato no you're done okay you're
down
it's amazing that it takes more shotgun
bullets and it takes actual normal
bullets well those look those look
active what duck oh hey how's it going
you're not gonna duck are you okay Oh
got knocked down did you you get knocked
down you get back up again okay I am
dead really what the hell no if there
are three turrets on the horizon it's
probably just better to look for a safer
path oh really Wow mister condescending
oh you think you're helping huh well
screw you buddy
screw you you know what i'ma throw a
grenade at you guys
oh come on well god damn it all right
find that oh yeah it's gonna okay save
for path you say whatever you think I
don't know safe I think I don't know
about safety huh
you gotta whoa Wow okay run Howie
oh all righty then man these turrets
luck are they everywhere how many how
many machine guns do I expect to believe
that they had in this place cuz goddamn
this is too many and it doesn't even
make sense
I know Lucas is supposed to be a genius
and all that some kind of southern
genius but there's too much do much for
my feeble mind to accept
I'm just backtracking now never get out
of here all right well I don't have I
don't have the necessary thing to defeat
to you so I'm gonna somehow go around
you huh all right well this is a
conundrum yeah I'm gonna just block I'm
blocking oh god you really got it
you really got a [ __ ] block the
coal-hole quarter oh no you didn't ha ha
all right I got it I got it I got a dick
okay all right what we got here
oh well I don't sound good but this
sounds good okay where am I now
bullets okay I got bullets lots of all
that's Oh should run okay lots of
bullets that's good yeah man every time
I hold my gun to my face I think that
the bombs oh whoa whoa whoa
don't blow he's gotta blow hmm
all right that was scary why all right
okay weird oh hey oh you're the weird
one
oh boy okay all right ah I got you f
okay oh boy oh boy what am i wha why am
I here why I'm here
oh boy why I'm here hey hey hey I don't
want none I don't want it oh okay all
right wait there was something there oh
okay well this sucks
where am I supposed to go then oh geez
oh geez oh geez maybe I can blow up that
barrel maybe I can blow up that barrel
yeah I won't blow up that barrel yeah
it's good plan mark yeah
firestorm get can I stomp I was tough no
I was trying to stop him Oh Oh follow up
well that didn't work out - whoa hey
sorry about that I didn't work out do
well for me okay all right well try one
more time yeah I don't have any more
ramrod I'm kind of a ram rotted out
if you know what I mean there's gotta be
oh you yeah you okay all right where was
I
[Music]
try shotgun Oh God he doesn't get
knocked over
not even a knock over a me like a knock
okay well that was easy
yeah yeah okay let me try to actually
get the stew how's it going okay let me
try to actually get the stomp on him
actually you know what do I even need to
bother why do I need to bother I should
just go this way hey okay okay I'm out
of here
boom well alright then well that was
easy
okie dokie alright well there you have
it so anyway that's all the time I got
for this one unless it's gonna be more
story as soon as I get out here was
there might be hello
no okay alright so thank you everybody
so much for watching I'm gonna finish
this up in the next episode of depending
on how long it is there no idea honestly
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see
in the next video
[Music]